[Music]
all right let's go to morgan in st louis
what's up morgan save us hey
hey hey i'm still googling about
diabetes in a bag
what's happening
oh hi thanks for having me on the uh the
greatest architecture podcast
so tell us about your architecture
challenges and um if you have some some
drainage issues or some roofing i don't
know
you know it's actually it's a decent
segway because i'm looking for some
guidance uh navigating living situations
post-divorce okay cool
yeah um hey you should work in radio
that was a fantastic transition from a
from a train wreck to an actual segment
yeah i'm not sure i'm cut out for that
um so my my now ex-husband we separated
last october
we
our divorce was final in march
um and we have three little boys they
are now ten nine and six holy smokes um
yeah so when when we divorced or even
when we separated we had two homes on
the property where we lived so he moved
into the old house i stayed in the house
we had remodeled
with the kiddos and committed to staying
here for 18 months to kind of give the
kids a transition
my folks joke that it's divorce fight
because they see both of us every day
they run back and forth um you know if
it's we're going to leave to school and
one of the boys says hey can i go
say hi to dad yes you can run on over so
it's been a good transition i believe
for our kids um but it's not forever
and the moves that i'm contemplating
moving off of the property he's going to
stay on the property he has a business
but he runs on the property so that
that's what makes sense but i don't see
us living 200 yards apart as viable
indefinitely
so i'm trying to evaluate kind of what's
next and i could choose to stay local
and
keep the kids in the same school live in
the same community
i have a lot of reasons to not want to
do that
i
personally would prefer to move out of
state
with the kids and
the the reasons that i have for that
i'll also revolve around them
my career
it materially matters i've been the sole
provider for our family for the last
four years as he's doing this start-up
and with really the dynamic that kind of
that probably destroyed our marriage and
um kind of persists is that i he he
views himself as peripheral to
the family
he's focused on providing he works all
the time
and
i just came back from vacation with the
kids um but we've vacationed alone for
the last like the children and i um for
the last
seven or eight years
um so
he's been working around the clock but
not earning anything he's just been busy
correct correct and i think i i have a
lot of compassion for that i don't think
he's trying to
um i don't think there's some
bad motivation i think he's fear driven
he's terrified to fail and so he just
keeps pouring and pouring and pouring
himself into
into his job and it's agriculture so
it's super demanding around the clock it
is hard to get away
um but
when we were navigating our divorce that
was the one thing that i told him was
look like we moved to this area we've
lived here four years
we moved here to be close to your family
we lived in texas for 11 years because
that was important for his family and
his career
we moved here to be close to his family
and for his career and i don't want to
be here until the kids are all graduated
from high school i'd like to move to be
closer to my family and a support
network for me um
and he agreed he said yes
it is written in a decree that i have
the right to move out of state with our
kiddos and that he intends to follow
and now you're the bad guy
um well i that's and that's obviously
like that will that will be the outcome
kind of no matter what happens
yes um
he has not said like i can't leave he
hasn't pushed back on that and said how
dare you he said well hey you know you
can go but i probably can't follow right
away or what is our custody agreement
going to look like if i can't move
and um
so i guess my question is
do my kids need their dad
in their lives
to like should i stay and keep pulling
my hair out juggling doing this dance
um or is that just facilitating him
being an
absentee parent more or less and not
being a partner and raising them and do
i
need to just say this is what he agreed
to and move on
and allow him to fail by not following
like what's best for my kids
this is hard um i
to answer that question with any sort of
certainty
i would want to spend a long time with
you and with him
let me talk around it a little bit is
that okay
yeah um
you said he's a person who's
probably deep down a good guy he's just
scared to fail
and
he's scared to fail so he's so scared to
fail that his marriage has failed his
business has failed
and now he's moved to a new place and
this business has failed and he just
hasn't called it yet um
so
he's made a lot of choices that um
revolved around him and his needs
and your kids your sons have got a
picture of what a dad is
what a husband is what a man is
and at this point i don't again
without talking to him seeing him
the external metrics are a pretty
uh dismal picture of what responsibility
looks like what character and integrity
looks like and character like
what eric thomas says it's simply saying
you're gonna do what you're what you
said you're gonna do and he hasn't done
that i would challenge you you have not
had a transition in those boys minds
y'all are not divorced you're just
living in other rooms
they have not experienced the weight of
this transition yet
and um i um let me roll back a little
bit
what ultimately led to the divorce did
somebody cheat on somebody uh did you
just have a nut like this just sounds
like you moved to the other room it just
happens that y'all got lucky and there
was two
properties i mean two houses on the
property
what led to the devil there was
there
it was um there was no one else it was
more or less me
um
i accommodated i enabled this dynamic
for years and it was me ultimately
saying this is too much
that you're not here i want you here
starting to actually articulate my needs
and
running up against the wall for
several years and ultimately
giving an ultimatum saying
i'm not going to continue like this
either we want the same things and
you're going to engage you're going to
start to see a therapist you're going to
start to find some some help to
be the kind of dad you're telling me you
want to be be the kind of husband you're
telling me you want to be or you're
going to say no that's not that's not
really what i'm in this for and we're
going to go our separate ways because
i'm not i'm not going to do this anymore
so
there's a there's a insidious form of
manipulation he he left you a long time
ago
yes he left you a long time ago
and he didn't leave
which makes it worse because then it
makes you feel crazy
is that fair accurate
and then
it's in counseling i there's there's a
million different definitions here but
it's the one down position
he's controlling everything from the woe
is me place we have to go move here
because i have to do this thing for you
what it's for you it's for them and
then you are left looking at the
electric bill saying somebody has to pay
this
and i can't go on vacations with y'all
because i'm doing this for y'all y'all
just go without me and it's fine right
and so it's just one down move and it's
a control mechanism
it's it's a um
all even has it's a cowardly control
mechanism it's it's pulling the boat
from under the water instead of having
the courage to sit up and say i want to
drive this way right and then you're
forced everyone in the boat
knows you're pulling it under the water
and they don't want to go this direction
but they
they have to cut the rope and then
you're waving in the water going what
happened what happened you know what i
mean so
this this i agree to everything in the
divorce decree
and then i'm gonna leave fine cool we're
gonna do what we said we're gonna do and
i'm gonna move out of state to where i
can get some support that i haven't had
in five years ten years 15 years
oh well i i i can't it's a it's the same
manipulation move it's the same one down
move would you just go ahead without me
and whenever i can get done doing all
this work for you and the kids and then
i'll i'll see if i can squeeze in some
you see what i'm saying it's a move it's
a move
um when you ask the question
do their boys need their dad the answer
is unequivocally yes
and
do the boys need a model
of a man who leaves his wife high and
dry
abandons them and her to the tune of
some job
pick lawyer farmer
architect whatever
is that a good representation no and
what those boys are gonna do if they
haven't already is they are gonna spend
their life trying to figure out what it
was about that tractor that was more
important than they were
and they're going to do things like you
just mentioned we need to go say hi to
dad he likes it when we because they're
trying to solve that relationship
problem
and you're going to take them out of
state and you're going to get some peace
in your life for the first time
and he's going to begin to say things
like well your mom took took you away
from me
and just be prepared the moment this
divorce happened you're now playing a
20-year game you are planting seeds for
the relationship with your 30 and 29 and
26 year old son
not your 14 and 13 year old sons okay
because they're gonna hate you
they're going to be pissed let me
rephrase that they're not going to hate
you they're going to love you deeply
they're going to say the words i hate
you they're going to be frustrated
they're going to be
what about right
that's part of this transition
and you're gonna have to go ahead
i can hear him saying like in my mind
because it's a refrain of things i've
heard for the last decade well i really
want to i really wish i could but i have
to work but it's you know xyz insert
excuse here that's right and i know that
that's how the move is going to go
is well i really wish i could be there
for such and such kiddos but your mom
moved you to you know wherever and it's
it's just too hard for me to get there
and there's going to be a victim card
that's right and the kids are going to
be mad at me and like
ultimately i hope they don't land there
indefinitely i hope they mature through
that and it gives them perspective to
see the dynamic for what it is but
that's why i'm i need to be confident in
whatever decision i make
to kind of navigate those waters for
myself so
let me reframe two things number one
you you hear you've heard me say this
all the time don't ever we're never
gonna talk negative we're never gonna
piss on on some kid's dad or mom right
so we're not gonna never talk negatively
about that and i think that's a fair
conversation to have with him
it is fair to say
um yeah i thought your dad was going to
come and move to the same city or the
same town and for now he's choosing to
stay here
that's not a mean statement that's not a
dishonest statement that's a very fair
honest statement
okay
and it would also be fair for him to
tell them
uh mom yeah me and mom agreed that um we
were gonna leave and she's choosing to
leave sooner or she's choosing to leave
now and i'm choosing to stay but the
truth is he's choosing to stay in not in
violation but counter to the agreement
y'all made right and he's he's a girl
man he's allowed to do that the second
thing i want to reframe is this you've
already made the decision
you divorced him
he left you you divorced them
the longer you hang on and pretend you
haven't made that decision the more
chaos intention and anxiety those kids
are going to absorb
it sounds like you haven't come to terms
with you divorced him
is that true that's a tough one
you know
i think what i haven't come to terms
with is
to your point
what the divorce really means for my
kids for me personally
i feel a million times more at peace i
feel like our home is more peaceful i
feel like life
there's
i
personally feel very comfortable in
terms of okay
you're playing both sides of the fence
because you know if you're if something
happens he's going to come over and help
he's right there
but i don't want him here
like you sound like you
are
ready to jump
are you ready to go i know the i know
the questions about the boys are all
well and good but they can't be used as
a proxy for your fear too are you scared
to go
no 100 i'm not and go and
initially initially some of that was
true like pipes froze well you know i
called him hey can you help me with this
but
that's been
that was the first couple months
um i've
i'm not leaning there at all at this
point very cool then now you just gotta
now you gotta
i'm gonna load the truck
yeah
and yes this this there is not a way in
the answer there's not a way to do this
without a lot of tears and a lot of
heartbreak and a lot of second guessing
and just because something hurts and
feels very painful doesn't mean it's not
the right decision
agreed
in a perfect world when you sat down
with him your husband and said
i'm tired of you um having an affair
with your imaginary jobs
and i'm tired of being a single mom
raising three young little boys
and i'm tired of having to explain to
three little boys why their daddy is
cheating on their family with a tractor
and
i need these things from you and he
looked at you and said
um
i hear you and i'm all in
and so you let your needs be heard
and he said i prefer to divorce you
and so you're carrying a lot of guilt
and a lot of shame and you got to set
that stuff down and be about living your
life
is that fair yep
yeah very
okay
it's this feels like a again
i'd feel much more confident my answer
if we were sitting down the three of us
me and you and your husband
but this feels like another move
and it's a power move it's just not a
loud beat your chest power move it's an
all shucks woe is me power move
but it's still a move
the divorces happen the divorce is final
you can't be roommates on the same place
um or at some point he brings home
somebody else or at some point you meet
somebody else
and that you know i mean like you can't
live like this it just becomes a strange
weird arrangement
and you need community and you need
support and if you don't have this here
in this little town then you need to go
back to your original plan and make your
plan happen and yes your boys are going
to be pissed and yes we're going to say
things like i hate you and i can't
believe you took us away from everything
we knew and loved we missed the farm but
all that stuff is going to be true
but they made also
have peace for the first time in their
entire life
they may have
a mom who's able to breathe for the
first time in her entire life and have
that rippled through
they're always gonna wonder what they
did
um what was wrong with them
that dad wouldn't go on vacation with
them the dad was more interested in
whatever than them
they're always gonna wonder why dad
picked this over mom my dad picked this
over that and they're always gonna
wonder why you took them away um and
hopefully um
you stay invested and you stay plugged
in you stay intentional even through the
storms because the storm's gonna come
you stay intentional through those
things and man when they're 18 19 20 25
30 they're gonna realize what a brave
powerful mom they have
and i'm sorry you're
sorry i've been through this this has
been a long time coming i'm sorry
i'm happy to walk with you through this
man um don't hesitate to call me morgan
if i can ever help all right um
best of luck